hi wir sind wieder für euch ZDF heute
live wir freuen uns sehr dass ihr bei
uns im Stream seid am 21 September
dieses Jahres ruft Wladimir Putin die
teil-mobilwachung in Russland aus Anfang
November erklärte sie dann offiziell für
beendet laut Kreml sein 300.000 Mann
mobilisiert und für den Krieg eingezogen
worden
87.000 von ihnen seien schon auch an die
Front geschickt worden mehr und mehr
Berichte zeigen uns jetzt aber dass die
Situation der Soldaten vor Ort an der
Front verheerend ist die Männer sein
ohne Ausbildung ohne Training in den
Krieg geschickt worden sein es Fehler an
Ausrüstung überall und auch an
Bekleidung für die kommenden Wintertage
dort Informationen des britischen
Geheimdienstes sind deswegen auch schon
zehntausende der Männer bereits
gestorben zum Sterben an die Front das
ist unser Thema heute und da geht auch
die erste Frage direkt an einen unserer
Gäste den ich jetzt ganz herzlich bei
uns begrüße das ist Nico lange
Politikwissenschaftler und auch Russland
Experte schön guten Abend Herr Lange
Frage an sie schickt Putin da
wissentlich teile seine Bevölkerung in
den sicheren Tod
guten Abend die Antwort auf diese Frage
lautet leider ja
die teilmobil machen die dann
Wirklichkeit mehr als das ist wo sehr
viele Soldaten eingezogen werden
dient ja dazu in einer Situation in der
man militärisch im Rückstand ist und
Territorium wieder verloren hat die
ukrainischen Angriffe irgendwie zu
bremsen und das macht man dadurch dass
man sehr schnell schlecht ausgebildete
schlecht ausgerüstete Soldaten an die
Front wirft die zwar den ukrainischen
Angriff verlangsamen die aber den
ukrainischen Kräften in sehr vielen
Fällen sehr wenig entgegenzusetzen haben
also sie werden im Grunde dafür geopfert
dass Russland Zeit gewinnt in diesem
Krieg weil Putin hofft dass er wenn er
Zeit gewinnt sich wieder neu aufstellen
kann Kräfte sammeln kann neue Waffen
vielleicht aus Nordkorea oder Iran
bekommen kann und damit dann sich wieder
gestärkt in einem neuen Angriff gegeben
kann also diese Leute werden
Herr Lange vielleicht ganz kurz noch
welche Informationen haben sie über die
Bedingungen und auch Zustände für die
Soldaten da vor Ort
das ist von Region zur Region und von
Einheit zu eineinhalb durchaus
unterschiedlich aber es gibt eben sehr
viele Berichte darüber dass Soldaten
keine Befehle bekommen dass sie nicht
ausgerüstet werden das verwandte und
Bekannte im russischen Online-Handel
erstmal die Ausrüstung zusammen kaufen
müssen dass die Vorgesetzten und das hat
ja in der russischen Armee leider
Tradition sehr brutal und rücksichtslos
mit diesen Soldaten umgehen dass sie
auch von älteren Soldaten misshandelt
werden und dass sie ganz besonders
bewusst vorgeschickt werden an Stellen
wo man weiß da ist es sehr gefährlich um
sie sozusagen zu opfern und es geht ja
bis dahin dass manche russische
Kommandeure sagen naja mit diese mobics
wie sie genannt werden also die neuen
mobilisierten Soldaten die werden auch
genutzt um mal zu gucken wo die Minen
liegen in den Minenfeldern und wo die
ukrainischen Stellungen genau sind also
das ist ein Umgang mit Menschen der
Menschen eben als Menschen Material be
und sie behandelt wie Gegenstände
danke für ihre ersten Erläuterungen und
Analysen zu dieser Situation wir
sprechen später im Stream weiter Herr
Lange vielen Dank bis hierhin und die
hat es gerade schon gesehen eingeblendet
fragen wie immer gerne an unseren
gesprächsgast per Mail oder auch in die
Kommentare wir haben das hier direkt
alles offen genau das was er lange da
beschreibt diese Sorge und Angst hatten
natürlich viele vor der teilmobil machen
sie haben das Land verlassen sie sind
desertiert tun das auch nach wie vor an
der Front und die Angst und der
Widerstand in der Bevölkerung er wächst
jetzt auch in Russland auch von den
Müttern und Frauen der Soldaten im Land
sie begehren gegen Putin auf das zeigt
sich das zeigen Berichte Alexandra
vakano zeigt uns jetzt über den zeigt
uns jetzt den Versuch der Frauen gegen
Putin aufzuklären
ihre Söhne sind in den Krieg gezogen die
Mütter extra vom Kreml ausgewählt heute
sitzen sie bei Kaffee und Gebäck mit dem
zusammen der den Angriff auf die Ukraine
gestartet hat das inszenierte treffen
live im russischen Fernsehen für eine
Mutter ist ihr Sohn egal wie alt er ist
immer ein Junge sagt Putin von den
Soldaten Müttern kein kritisches Wort
zum Krieg außerhalb der kreml-mauern
schon Kritik das sei eine weitere
putinvorstellung gewesen heißt es von
einer verbotenen Vereinigung der Mütter
und Ehefrauen diese Frauen waren von der
Volksfront waren Abgeordnete das war ein
Treffen das vereinbart wurde aber das
war wieder ein Dialog unter sich die
Volksfront wird von Putin angeführt
verrostete Sturmgewehre alte russische
Panzer die Soldaten sind schlecht
ausgestattet beklagen viele Frauen und
Mütter warum gibt es keine richtige
militärische Ausbildung keine richtige
technische Ausstattung sie sagen es ist
an der Zeit zu handeln nicht zu denken
und nicht darauf zu warten dass alle in
diesem verdammten Fleischwolf zerlegt
werden die Stimme der Soldatenmütter in
früheren Kriegen einst eine lautere
Stimme
und Test und Oppositionen sind in
Russland seit dem Februar 2022 viel
schwieriger sind mit sehr viel höheren
Repressionen verbunden so dass wir hier
nicht davon ausgehen können dass es hier
zu groß und Protesten jetzt erstmal
kommen diese Mütter und Frauen haben
ihre Kinder und Ehemänner verloren der
russische general drückt sein Beileid so
aus
meine Mutter sagte diesen wundervollen
Satz von heute an gehörst du nicht zu
mir du gehörst dem Land der Heimat
was gibt es darüber hinaus für Deutungen
dieses Treffens und auch der Aussagen
vom Kreml und welche Auswirkungen kann
das Aufbegehren der Frauen auch für den
Kreml haben generell auch wie ist der
Stand des Widerstands in Russland gegen
Putin und gegen den russischen
Angriffskrieg das sind drei Schwerpunkte
und drei Fragen mit denen ich vor der
Sendung mit einer der bekanntesten
Anthropologin in Russlands sprechen
konnte und das ist Alexandra akipova sie
hat nach Ausbruch des Krieges im Februar
das Land verlassen und forscht jetzt an
der Forschungsstelle Osteuropa der
Universität in Bremen weiter und als
erstes wollte ich von ihr wissen wie Sie
diese Bilder des Treffens heute deutet
und wie gefährlich das Aufbegehren der
Frauen für Putin werden kann
ich habe zugehört wie Putin mit diesen
Müttern gesprochen hat
über den nice und er hat wirklich sehr
freundliche Worte gefunden er spricht
für ein sehr netter Mensch oder ist ein
Grund dafür
der Grund ist das offensichtlich der
Kreml sich gut stellen will mit den
Müttern denn man sieht sie
offensichtlich als Bedrohung an
die Mütter und die Angehörigen die
könnten ja irgendwie reagieren auf die
Mobilisierung denn während der letzten
zwei Monate
da gab es ganz viele Videoaufnahmen
sowohl von mobilisierten russischen
Soldaten und auch von den Verwandten den
Müttern den Ehefrauen dieser
mobilisierten Soldaten
und das ist ein indirekter Kontext
gewesen denn in Russland ist es so dass
man nicht direkt protestieren kann das
geht einfach nicht man kann sofort
bestraft werden
man geht sofort ins Gefängnis
nur wenn man einen kleinen Versuch
startet zu protestieren dazu gehört auch
ein Poster in den sozialen Medien also
das kann man nicht machen
was aber viel wichtiger ist ist dass
die Proteste in Russland
die sind jetzt so gefährlich geworden
dass die meisten Menschen nicht mal mehr
daran denken können was würden Sie sagen
wird sich dieser Protest dieser
Widerstand der Frauen in der nächsten
Zeit noch weiter ausbauen und wie
gefährlich kann es dann auch für
Vladimir Putin werden wenn das so
weitergeht im eigenen Land
also die Menschen die da protestieren
die kommen ja aus der gleichen Gruppe
die normalerweise Putin unterstützen
das sind seine Wähler
und der Kreml möchte diese Wähler nicht
verlieren
und die organisieren sich in
verschiedenen Städten in ganz kleinen
Köpfchen und die nehmen also diese
Videos auf und weil die aktiv keinen
Protest gegen den Krieg selber machen
deswegen können diese Videos auch sehr
schnell über das russische Internet
geteilt werden und das machen die Leute
auch Frau Aki sagen gerade dass diese
Proteste der Frauen aber keine Proteste
gegen den Krieg an sich sind ist es das
nicht weil die Frauen wissen unmögliche
Konsequenzen oder weil sie auch selber
weiter auch an diesen Krieg glauben
ich denke sie versuchen sich selber als
so wenig unloyal darzustellen wie
möglich zumindest öffentlich wollen sie
keine
iloyalität zeigen sie zeigen sich
praktisch
wenn sie sich als Oppositionelle zum
brennende zeigen wird wird sie unpopulär
denn jeder hat ja Angst in Russland im
Moment
spielen praktisch ein Spiel sie sagen
wir sind nicht gegen den Krieg wir sind
dagegen unsere Söhne in diesen Krieg zu
schicken
das ist so ein Spiel im Grunde genommen
also ob man sagt
das ist
schwarz und dann sagt man eben nicht
Krieg sondern schwarz wir wissen nicht
was in den Köpfen dieser Frauen vorgeht
aber eins ist klar die sind nicht
glücklich über das was passiert
jetzt haben wir diese Informationen auch
das was Sie beschreiben wir haben auch
die Bilder direkt nach der
mobilenmachung Putins wo 10.000 auch aus
dem Land geflüchtet sind sie sagen wir
können nicht in die Köpfe der Menschen
der Bevölkerung schauen aber was wissen
Sie über den Widerstand in der
russischen Bevölkerung in Bezug auf den
russischen Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine generell
also es gibt sehr viel Widerstand
man kann nicht auf die Straße gehen in
großen Zahlen denn man wird sofort
gestoppt von der Polizei und man kommt
ins Gefängnis also das kann man nicht
machen aber viele Leute erfinden
sogenannte indirekte Proteste
zum Beispiel
haben sie ukrainische Bänder in der Hand
oder die tragen normale Kleidung aber in
der Farbe der ukrainischen Flagge
oder Sie machen kleine Graffitis die sie
an die Wände die Malta Graffiti an der
Wende und ähnliche Dinge
und man kann sagen
das Widerstandes sind das kann man
sicherlich sagen aber wenn man für einen
kleinen Aufkleber fünfjahres Gefängnis
geht und für einen Satz kann man sieben
Jahre ins Gefängnis gehen
der Preis so hoch ist ist das wirklich
tatsächlich ein Akt des Widerstandes auf
der anderen Seite läuft seit Jahrzehnten
vom Kreml von Putin auch die riesige
Propa gandamaschinerie auch ein
Informationskrieg läuft der natürlich
auch die anderen Teile der Bevölkerung
erreicht wie ist da denn das Verhältnis
wer glaubt denn dass der Krieg gut ist
und wer eben nicht
das wissen wir nicht aber nach Umfragen
also was wird daher wissen ist dass die
Unterstützung des Krieges immer weiter
runter geht
[Musik]
und die Leute sind einfach immer
unzufriedener mit der Situation
und
zuletzt ging also die Zustimmung um 20
Punkte zurück das ist eine Menge
und es gibt sehr viel Angst also das
Angstniveau ist sehr hoch in Russland
jetzt im November viel höher als im
September z.B und höher als
am Beginn des Krieges also schaut so aus
als ob die russische Gesellschaft im
Moment wirklich spürt was da passiert
und ich muss sagen die Propaganda ist
ziemlich wirksam denn sehr viel soziale
Medien werden blockiert viele Zeitungen
werden blockiert und jede Information
die man bekommen kann sagt praktisch
alles ist wunderbar es gibt ein paar
Probleme aber es gibt keinen Krieg und
es wird einfach alles [ __ ]
vielen Dank Frau akipova für dieses
Gespräch und diese Einblicke
ich danke Ihnen
und genau die angesprochenen Punkte die
vertiefen wir jetzt mit Nico lange
Politikwissenschaftler und
russland-experte bei uns im Stream
begrüße sie nochmal Frau akipova
beobachtet also einen wachsenden
Widerstand wachsenden Protest auch von
Frauen von Müttern der Soldaten und eine
sinkende Unterstützung innerhalb der
Bevölkerung für den Krieg Herr Lange
woran liegt das
zunächst muss man in einer Diktatur die
so lange Zeit aufgebaut worden ist wie
die Diktatur Putins zwischen den Zeilen
lesen und es sind ja die Gesetze darüber
was man sagen darf in Bezug auf diesen
Krieg darüber wie man Protest äußern
darf oder eben nicht äußern darf noch
mal erheblich verschärft worden deswegen
erfordert es zum einen enorm viel Mut
dagegen etwas zu unternehmen weil man
eben für viele Jahre ins Gefängnis
gelangen kann und zum anderen sind es
subtile Formen mit denen man protestiert
aber man muss immer genau aufpassen dass
die Botschaft bei den Menschen die das
sehr gut verstehen ankommt aber dass man
gleichzeitig nicht diese gesetzlichen
Rahmen überschritt und dann eben nicht
mehr wirksam sein kann das haben wir
glaube ich auch bei diesem Treffen der
Soldaten Mütter mit Wladimir Putin
gesehen und das sehen wir auch in vielen
anderen Formen und das weniger geschulte
Auge
mit Diktaturen erkennt das vielleicht
gar nicht als Protest ich bin mir aber
sicher die Menschen die schon lange in
so einem autoritären System leben müssen
die erkennen diese Protestformen genau
und deswegen sind sie auch wichtig dass
sie sichtbar sind und sichtbar bleiben
können Sie das vielleicht noch mal
konkretisieren also wie deuten sie dann
diese Aktionen der Frauen also warum
sehen sie das als deutlichen Protest
die Soldaten Mütter haben ja eine lange
Geschichte und die sind sehr gefährlich
für Putin weil sie schon in vorher
gegangenen kriegen zum Beispiel
Tschetschenienkrieg sehr stark die
Gesellschaft mobilisiert haben weil über
die Soldaten Mütter eben deutlich wird
dass russische Männer im Krieg sterben
und das ist ein so unmenschlichen Umgang
der russischen Streitkräfte mit den
eigenen russischen Soldaten gibt und
deswegen muss Putin auch so ein Treffen
auch wenn das jetzt sehr inszeniert wird
wie heute machen weil er sich nicht
leisten kann nicht zu reagieren auf
mögliche Proteste der Soldaten Mütter
und das sind sicherlich auch einige
dabei die Schauspielerinnen sind und
eigentlich zu Putin gehören das ist
immer so in diesem System aber
gleichzeitig zeigt uns das er muss das
ernst nehmen weil er Probleme hat mit
diesen Krieg und der Hintergrund ist
doch
die Mobilisierung die teilmobil machen
die sogenannte die in Wirklichkeit mehr
ist hat zu einer inneren Front geführt
in Russland sie ist chaotisch abgelaufen
sind ja Leute teilweise aus ihren
Häusern oder von der U-Bahn Weg zu den
Streitkräften rekrutiert wurden und es
fallen unheimlich viele russische
Soldaten an der Front weil sie schlecht
ausgebildeten schlecht ausgerüstet da
kämpfen müssen und über diese Zustände
berichten sie ja auch nach Hause über
die Mobiltelefone über Videos kommt sehr
viel in Russland gerade an und ich
glaube Putin versucht gerade diesen
Unmut irgendwie zu managen
entscheidende Nachfrage kommt er von
unserem User no Saint bei Youtube diese
Zustände diese Umstände diese
beschreiben und das ist eine klare Frage
wie steht's denn dann auch um die
Kampfmoral der weiteren russischen
Soldaten die das ja auch mitbekommen
russischen Soldaten ist ja von Anfang an
in diesem Krieg schon sehr niedrig sie
sind in einem Krieg geschickt worden
unter der Illusion man müsste da nur
nach Kia fahren und die Leute würden
sich entweder passiv verhalten unter
oder die russischen Soldaten sogar
begrüßen und werden aber mit dem aller
härtesten Widerstand nicht nur der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte sondern der
gesamten ukrainischen Gesellschaft
konfrontiert und das ist etwas nur mit
die nicht gerechnet haben und womit die
einfach auf die auch nicht vorbereitet
waren und mit schlechter Ausrüstung und
schlechter Ausstattung wenn viele
Kameraden in der Einheit schon gefallen
sind da ist natürlich die Motivation
extrem niedrig aber gleichzeitig ist das
System der Depressionen und der Zwang
und die Unterdrückung so groß dass man
gar keine Wahl hat als da irgendwie zu
kämpfen oder es ganz schwer hat sich dem
zu widersetzen es gibt aber eine ganze
Reihe von Soldaten die sich lieber
verhaften lassen als dass sie da
weiterkämpfen oder die ja das weiß man
ja zu zigtausenden das Land verlassen
haben um sich vor diesen Zuständen zu
drücken und das ist wirklich traurig
dass mit anzusehen dass ein Land das so
eine Rhetorik und solche Worte von sich
gibt wie Putin so absolut unmenschlich
mit den eigenen Leuten umgeht und sie in
so eine sinnlose
Kampfhandlung schickt und ein Beispiel
es gibt ein Schlachtfeld in diesem Krieg
bei einer ukrainischen Stadt die heißt
bachmut wo seit Monaten also wirklich
seit Monaten die russischen Soldaten
immer wieder dorthin geworfen werden um
diese Stadt zu erobern dort ist nichts
erreicht worden seit Monaten nicht aber
es sind extrem viele tausende russische
Soldaten gestorben völlig sinnlos und
das ist finde ich symbolisch dafür wie
Putin diesen Krieg führt und wie er ihn
ohne Rücksicht auf die eigenen Menschen
führt wir schauen noch gleich gemeinsam
Herr Lange auf die weiteren Situation in
Sachen Frontverlauf und auf den Ausblick
für den Kriegsverlauf bleiben vielleicht
jetzt auch noch mal bei den Aspekten und
den Situationen sie haben es
angesprochen
weite Teile und viele sind auch schon
vor der teilmobil machen und als sie
bekannt geworden ist geflüchtet aus dem
Land und da kommt die Frage von
Christian die sich daran anschließt
stellen die geflüchteten Russen die
jetzt im Ausland sind nicht auch ein
großes Potenzial für eine echte
Opposition aus dem Ausland gegenüber
Russland da wie würden sie das
einschätzen
ich muss gestehen ich bin da
also zum einen scheint es Leute zu geben
die nicht von dem System Putin benutzt
werden wollen und die auch schon länger
von Putin nichts gehalten haben aber zum
anderen muss man glaube ich ganz
nüchtern festhalten das ist sehr sehr
viele Russen gab die gesagt haben der
Krieg ist ganz gut aber ich will eben
nicht in diesem Krieg kämpfen wäre gut
wenn es jemand anders macht und sobald
es dazu kam dass man jetzt selbst
kämpfen sollte
dann fliegt man lieber das heißt aber
nicht automatisch dass man gegen
russischen nationalismus ist oder dass
man dagegen ist gegen die Ukraine zu
kämpfen sondern das ist glaube ich auch
schon ganz egoistisches Motiv also da
muss man unterscheiden und ein Potenzial
für die Opposition werden sie ja wenn
sie in Russland bleiben würden
und in vielen Ländern in der Nähe
Russlands also zum Beispiel in
Kasachstan wo jetzt sehr viele sind oder
auch in Georgien muss man sich auch die
Frage stellen diese Russen die er bis
vor kurzem Putin unterstützt haben auf
den Krieg unterstützt haben sind die
nicht auch eine Gefahr für diese Länder
und sind die nicht auch durchaus ein
mögliches Sicherheitsrisiko wenn die zu
uns kommen also zumindest muss man da
genau hinschauen
da sprechen Sie auch einen Teil und ein
Aspekt an den wir hier bei ZDF heute
live auch in einem weiteren
ausführlichen Stream behandelt haben
könnt ihr liebe Userinnen und User euch
natürlich auch gerne noch mal anschauen
der Titel ist sollte bezieht sich dann
auf Deutschland eben diese russischen
Kriegsdienst Verweigerer aufnehmen
könnte euch gerne anschauen Herr Lange
eine weitere Frage die auch noch mal in
Sachen mobil machen kommt ist von PK das
ist der User der wird ganz gerne noch
mal wissen welche Bevölkerungsteile und
Schichten von dieser mobil machen
betroffen waren und sind dann ist nach
wie vor ethnische Minderheiten oder hat
sich das geändert
das ist eine sehr gute Frage
weil Russland ja eine grausame Tradition
hat und die Tradition des russischen
Imperiums ist an seiner Peripherie sein
Territorium zu erweitern und die neuen
Territorien dann dazu nutzen um dort
Soldaten zu rekrutieren um die dann für
weitere Eroberung einzusetzen und wir
haben das ja in Don jetzt und luganst
auch gesehen auch auf der Krim russland
hat diese Gebiete annektiert hat sich
dort in die Ukraine begeben militärisch
und hat extrem viele Männer aus diesen
Regionen rekrutiert für die eigenen
Streitkräfte und damit sie dann kämpfen
müssen für Russland das waren ja ganz
brutale Zwangsrekrutierung vor allen
Dingen im Don Bass und es sind sehr
viele Soldaten aus ethnischen
Minderheiten voraus von den borienten
oder aus japuzien oder aus dageistan
rekrutiert worden für die Streitkräfte
das hat aber dort auch durchaus zu
Widerstand gefühlt gerade bei der
Teilnehmer machen
so dass man auch darüber hinaus nach
Soldaten gesucht hat da hat man sich
dann aber zum Beispiel in Moskau
durchaus mit besser gestellten Russen
angelegt man hat sich auch mit
Unternehmen angelegt die ihre
Arbeitskräfte verloren haben also diese
Mobilmachung hat für sehr viele
Konflikte gesorgt in Russland und Putin
ist immer noch mit den Folgen
beschäftigt und das ist ja in Russland
mittlerweile Konsens selbst bei den
Unterstützern von Protein dass diese
teilmobil machen im Grunde nur zu Ärger
geführt hat
die Frage was macht das eigentlich mit
diesen ethnischen Minderheiten in
Russland die dort man muss das so brutal
sagen verheizt werden in diesem Krieg
die ist auch noch nicht zu beende zu
Ende beantwortet da gibt es sehr viel
Unruhe und das wird man weiter
beobachten müssen ob der russische Staat
in der Lage ist diese Unruhe eigentlich
dauerhaft zu managen eine Anschlussfrage
noch als Abschluss auch zum Komplex der
Mobilmachung kommt vom User Elektron er
fragt sind die Grenzen vielleicht haben
sie da Informationen in Russland noch
offen um eventuell vor dem Krieg zu
flüchten bzw dem Krieg zu entfliehen
oder ist das nicht der Fall
die Grenzen sind nicht offen und das ist
auch ein Beispiel dafür wie dieses
russische autoritäre System lernt man
hat ja zum Beispiel an der Grenze zu
Georgien als dort viele Männer geflohen
sind einfach dort ein
mobilisierungsposten aufgemacht um den
Menschen die dort an der Grenze
eigentlich fliehen wollten einfach dort
den mobilisierungsbescheid auszuhändigen
oder man hat verboten das
Fluggesellschaften Tickets an Männer
verkaufen dürfen also sind ganz
systematisch alle Möglichkeiten sich der
mobil machen zu entziehen und zu fliehen
geschlossen worden und jetzt ist es so
wenn man von der mobil machen bedroht
ist in Russland dann hat man keinen
Ausweg mehr
außer und das haben wir ja auch Bilder
davon gesehen man weigert sich wirklich
und lässt sich lieber ins Gefängnis
stecken und das tun auch einige es gibt
aber einige Unternehmen die ihre Leute
sozusagen rausgeholt haben und der
Bürgermeister von Moskau hat ja auch
frühzeitig durchgesetzt aufgrund der
Proteste das in Moskau digital wo wir
machen ausgesetzt wurde also da merkt
man schon da regt sich einiges an
Widerstand aber rauskommt man nicht und
doch noch eine Anschlussfrage kommt
gerade ganz frisch rein von Max faulting
er fragt man hört auch immer wieder
Berichte dass verschiedene russische
Militäreinheiten sich nahe der Front
sogar gegenseitig bekämpfen würden ist
da was dran
und das russische Militär das in der
Ukraine kämpft ist ja keine einheitliche
Gruppe dort gibt es Kräfte der regulären
Streitkräfte da gibt es aber auch
unterschiedliche Truppengattungen zum
Beispiel die fallschirmjägerkräfte oder
die Artillerie oder Infanterieeinheiten
es gibt aber auch Spezialeinheiten die
von sich ein sehr militäres Verständnis
haben und die anderen Soldaten als
minderwertig betrachten aber es gibt
auch private Militärfirmen wie zum
Beispiel die sehr bekannte Partnergruppe
und die ist dafür bekannt dass sie gegen
auch russische Soldaten brutal vorgeht
und ja häufig auch die russischen
Soldaten wenn Sie sich zum Beispiel
zurückziehen weil sie eine Niederlage
erleiden brutal zwingt wieder an die
Frauen zurückzukehren oder sogar mit
Gewalt gegen eigene russische Leute
vorgehen und das gleiche gilt auch für
die Kadir of city also diese Truppen von
kadirus aus Tschetschenien die
eigentlich dem russischen
Innenministerium unterstehen also da
gibt's ganz viele unterschiedliche
Gruppierungen und es gibt sicherlich
auch zwischen den Anführern dieser
Gruppierung also zum Beispiel
kadirov aus Tschetschenien und Herr
pregorien der diese wagnergruppe leitet
zwischen denen gibt es auch Konkurrenz
und Wettbewerb deswegen gibt es da viele
interne Konflikte und extrem schlechte
Stimmung und häufig auch Gewalt bisschen
dazu dass diese Einheiten sich auch
untereinander bekämpfen wie lange jetzt
haben wir ganz fokussiert auf die
Probleme und auch auf die offenbar
gegenseitigen Bekämpfungen der
russischen Soldaten und der Armeen
geschaut lassen Sie uns den Blick weiten
auch hier im Chat ist immer wieder auch
die Kommentare und die Stimmung so dass
natürlich die ukrainische Seite und auch
ukrainische Mütter ihre Kinder ihre
Männer verlieren also einen sinnloses
Blut vergießen in diesem
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg wir
hatten gestern hier bei ZDF heute live
eine Sendung mit dem österreichischen
Bundeswehr Mitglied Oberst Reißner und
er sieht gerade mit Blick auf den
weiteren Kriegsverlauf schon einen
kritischen Punkt weil das ist auch
angesprochen im Chat die
in der Luft die Raketenangriffe der
Russen die zivile Infrastruktur in der
Ukraine treffen wir haben da Bilder
gesehen dass Kiew einen Tag lang die
Menschen von der Wasserversorgung
abgeschnitten worden waren auch immer
wieder die Stromnetze einbrechen sehen
sie da im Gesamtblick gerade auch einen
kritischen Punkt des Krieges oder wie
ordnen Sie das ein
die Lage ist schwierig
und gerade weil Russland an der Front
nicht vorankommt und zuletzt bei Herr
Sonja auch eine sehr einschneidende
Niederlage erlitten hat verlegt Putin
sich jetzt darauf mit Angriffen auf
Energieinfrastrukturen auf die
Wasserversorgung auf heizinfrastrukturen
ein Krieg gegen die Zivilbevölkerung in
der Ukraine zu führen das sind
Kriegsverbrechen dieser verübt werden
die darauf zielen dass man die Ukraine
entleert von den Menschen dass die Leute
fliegen müssen dass man auch nicht nur
in Kauf nimmt sondern befördern will
dass die Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine
erfrieren in diesem Winter in der
Hoffnung dass sie dann einknicken
und Putin Nachgeben der ja alle seine
Maximalziel oder für diesen Krieg weiter
aufrecht erhält ich glaube dass das
keine Wirkung hat auf die Motivation der
Ukrainer das ist die Motivation sogar
noch verstärkt aber das ist eine
kritische Situation herbeiführt in der
die Frage sind wir eigentlich ein
Beobachter oder wollen wir dazu
beitragen dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg
beenden können immer wichtiger wird und
Deutschland in die internationaler
Gemeinschaft tun viel aber noch nicht
genug um die Situation wirklich
zugunsten der Ukraine zu entscheiden
dann muss noch mehr passieren
und an der Front ist es eben so dadurch
dass die zum Beispiel die russischen
Streitkräfte jetzt verstärkt sind durch
Einheiten die aus dem Gebiet herson
abgezogen worden sind sind die Angriffe
und die weitere Befreiung des eigenen
Territoriums für die Ukraine schwieriger
geworden und die Russen gehen mit den
Menschen so um wie mit Menschen Material
also da ist es relativ irrelevant und
wir haben das ja bei bachmund gerade
gesehen ob da jetzt tausende russische
Soldaten sterben müssen für ein paar
Meter Land gewinnen aber die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte gehen so nicht
vor und die versuchen Verluste zu
vermeiden und deswegen ist es so ein
ganz unterschiedliche Herangehensweise
der Streitkräfte und dadurch wird es
also langsam und schwierig
die Ukraine hat nicht genügend
Kampfpanzer und Schützenpanzer um
mechanisierte Angriffe im Süden und im
Osten des Landes zu führen sie muss sich
auf andere Dinge verlegen und was die
Infrastrukturen angeht muss man leider
feststellen ja es kommt jetzt
Luftverteidigung auch aus Deutschland
sehr gute Luft Verteidigung auch aus
anderen Partnerstaaten aber diese
luftverteidigungssysteme kommen spät und
sie kommen langsam so dass Russland die
Gelegenheit hatte bei den
Infrastrukturen Schäden herbeizuführen
die nicht so einfach repariert werden
können man kann das vielleicht kurz
flicken und man kann dafür sorgen dass
es ab und zu mal wieder Strom und Wasser
gibt aber bestimmte Ersatzteile sind
ganz schwer zu beschaffen es ist auch
bei kalten Temperaturen sehr schwer die
Dinge zu reparieren also da ist eine
ganz kritische Situation entstanden
insbesondere für die Ziele
Zivilbevölkerung in der Ukraine
ich sage noch einen Satz weil
der mit der russischen
Bombardierung der Städte ja häufig das
Argument verbunden wird wir müssen jetzt
die Ukrainer so lange mit Raketen
beschießen dass sie aufgeben und das ist
Verhandlungen gibt
und jetzt kann man sagen sollen die
Ukraine doch nachgeben sonst wird es
leid noch viel größer
aber zum einen sind die Infrastrukturen
jetzt kaputt die werden auch dadurch
dass man plötzlich verhandelt nicht
wieder heil davon geht auch nicht die
Heizung an und der Strom ist wieder da
diese Dinge sind zerstört und zum
anderen ist es so dass die Ukraine mit
allergrößter Mehrheit über 90% aktuell
Daten der Meinung sind Russland muss das
ukrainische Territorium komplett
verlassen nur dann wird es Frieden geben
und es muss jetzt ein für alle Mal
dieser Krieg entschieden werden damit
Russland nicht jetzt ukrainisches Gebiet
behält sich wieder neu stark macht und
wieder neu angreift und das ist wirklich
die ganz entschieden verbreitete
Stimmung unter den Ukrainern trotz
dieser schwierigen Situation
umso entscheidender sind natürlich auch
die nächsten Wochen und Monate sie haben
kalte Temperaturen thematisiert der
Winter steht bevor der Winter kommt auch
in der Ukraine und da kommt auch die
nächste user-frage von Max mauting rein
wie bereiten sich da jetzt beide Seiten
an den Fronten auf diesen Wintereinbruch
vor und vielleicht ergänze ich auch noch
eine was sind da gerade beide Strategien
wer hat die bessere Position und wie
wird sich das entwickeln
die
taktische Vorbereitung kann man glaube
ich jetzt sehr deutlich erkennen
russland versucht mit aller Macht
bachmut habe ich angesprochen es gibt
einen Ort weiter südlich also westlich
von Don jetzt der heißt also da passiert
das gleiche russland versucht mit aller
Macht Ortschaften zu erobern
das passiert deswegen weil es einfacher
ist in den Ortschaften zu überwintern
wenn man dort die Infrastrukturen die
Gebäude die Versorgung nutzen kann und
vor dem Wetter geschützt ist und ist
natürlich viel schwieriger im Winter auf
dem offenen Feld oder im Schützengraben
zu überwintern und es gibt jetzt so eine
taktische Auseinandersetzung darüber wer
eigentlich die bessere Position hat und
zu überwintern Russland ist bis dahin
nicht erfolgreich und ist da in einer
ganz schwierigen Situation das gilt auch
für das Gebiet lugans weiter im Norden
man muss aber auch festhalten man darf
keine Bilder von einem Winterkrieg im
Kopf haben wie man das vielleicht aus
historischen Filmen kennt oder aus
Dokumentation über den Zweiten Weltkrieg
an der schwarzenbergküste wird es zwar
kalt aber das ist jetzt nicht so kalt
wie in Sibirien und z.B bei den
Ukrainern die sehr viele auch gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge geliefert bekommen haben die
auf Rädern sind also nicht auf Ketten
sondern auf Rädern wird die Mobilität
also die Möglichkeit sich zu bewegen ja
eher wieder größer wenn der Boden
gefroren ist und nicht so schlammig ist
wie jetzt also wir werden da auch im
Winter eine Fortsetzung der
Kampfhandlungen sehen auf beiden Seiten
aber die Frage ob man im Stadt oder in
der Stadt oder auf dem Feld überwintern
muss ist schon für die betroffenen
Soldaten und für die Betroffenen
Einheiten dann ganz erheblicher
Unterschied und darum geht es im Moment
wir werden genau über diese Situation
auch in den kommenden Wochen weiter
berichten hier bei ZDF heute live vielen
Dank für den Moment an Nico lange
Politikwissenschaftler und Russlands
Russland Experte danke für ihre Analysen
und für ihre Zeit hier bei uns heute
danke natürlich auch wie immer an euch
fürs Teil der Sendung sein fürs Fragen
stellen fürs kommentieren fürs mit
diskutieren und dann würden wir uns sehr
freuen wenn ihr bei ZDF heute live
weiter dran bleibt wir werden die
Situation rund um den russischen
Angriffskrieg immer weiter im Blick
haben analysieren und euch damit
fundierten Fakten versuchen helfen die
Situation einzuschätzen vielen Dank bis
hierhin und bis zum nächsten Mal macht's
gut tschüss
[Musik]